bom dia pessoal bom gente vai falar um
pouquinho sobre memes da internet né é a
minha primeira preocupação até
conversando aqui fora do palco é não
cair tropeçar cometeu uma gafe porque
imaginem só uma palestra de meme que
virou meme
então não é o caso ou conversar um
pouquinho com vocês sobre aquilo que a
gente pensa né
sem a zoeira na internet eu acho que
todo mundo aqui já recebeu um emmy
seja no instagram no facebook enfim no
twitter todo mundo de alguma forma já se
relacionou com essa linguagem
mas o que eu queria conversar com vocês
hoje é o seguinte porque a gente precisa
falar sobre os memes será que os mesmos
é só brincadeira zoeira diversão
será que tem alguma coisa mais
importante por trás dos memes que eu
acho que isso que é o recado que eu
queria deixar pra vocês pra gente pensar
refletir durante a palestra como que os
memes influenciam a nossa vida
será que a linguagem dos memes ela muda
a forma como se comunica com o outro
será que essas mensagens curtas e de
mortes a paródia está mudando a nossa
forma de se relacionar com o mundo e é
por isso que a gente precisa falar sobre
os memes né
eu acho que é interessante a primeira
coisa que a gente pensar é que os
membros dizem muito sobre o mundo que a
gente vive
o que eu quero dizer sabe aquela
sensação que o dia está passando rápido
é que de repente você presta atenção
nossa já em setembro
nossa daqui a pouco já é natal nossa eu
não consigo fazer tudo que eu queria
fazer tudo sempre acelerado correndo é
pensando no que eu posso produzir ou não
essa sensação diz muito sobre os memes
os menores não são obra do acaso eles
não são um sucesso porque são engraçados
e divertidos
claro todo mundo dá risada interessante
mas eu acho que o mais importante de se
pensar sobre os memes é que eles
representam muito a vida que a gente
leva corrida acelerada efêmera e por
isso que quando a gente está falando
sobre sobre os memes na verdade está
falando sobre a nossa vida
sobre as relações que a gente está
construindo
então além da brincadeira e da zoeira
que todo mundo conhece isso é o mais
importante
que tipo de relação a gente está
construindo um com o outro e como eu já
disse a velocidade é um aspecto
impressionante dos memes né então
ninguém faz um meme pensando daqui um
ano ao fazer um homem porque daqui um
ano todo mundo vai lembrar não todo
mundo faz um mesmo pensando em um curto
que aconteceu alguma coisa para brincar
para odiar enfim fazer uma zoeira né e
com essa idéia de divertimento rápido
que é um divertimento rápido é aquilo
que você passa a alina sua timeline do
facebook do twitter você dá risada acha
divertido e pronto sumir o cabo já foi
ninguém vai lembrar a manhã se eu
perguntar pra vocês alguém lembra de
três meses de ontem de anteontem na
semana passada dificilmente a gente vai
lembrar justamente porque a
característica do meme é essa
divertimento rápido e imediato e efêmero
bom nesse exercício que estou propondo
para vocês a gente pensar além da
brincadeira da zoeira tem algo muito
importante que eu queria conversar com
vocês hoje que é o próprio funcionamento
da internet
muitas vezes a gente recebe um meme nem
pensa como é que funciona a dinâmica da
internet e das redes sociais na e
principalmente dessa palavra chave que
são os algoritmos não queria falar pra
vocês rapidinho como é que essa dinâmica
para a gente entender porque a gente
gosta tanto dos memes vamos lá vamos
pensar que aqui fora é a internet
contudo que a gente conhece redes
sociais google facebook
enfim toda todo o universo da internet e
ali dentro somos nós né sou eu
vocês enfim percebam que por volta aqui
nesse círculo a gente tem uma série de
empresas né ea rua hugo google facebook
está nem vocês podem pensar em todas as
empresas de internet que trabalham que
acontece pessoal
tudo que a gente recebe nas redes
sociais é editado o que eu quero dizer
alguém seleciona aquilo que eu vou ver
certo porque imagine só se você tem mil
no facebook por exemplo é impossível
você acompanhar tudo o que seu amigo
está compartilhando que está apostando
alguém seleciona aquilo que você vai ver
e quem faz essa seleção os algoritmos e
os algoritmos estão aqui selecionando
tudo o que você vai ver tudo que você
vai curtir compartilhar enfim criando
esse fenômeno aqui consegue reparar o
que aconteceu porque não tem vermelho
verde amarelo
dentro daquela bolha e essa é uma idéia
de um pesquisador chamado eli pariser né
que é o norte americano que chama esse
fenômeno aqui de filtro bolha
o que a bolha é exatamente essa
organização da informação pra te atender
sob medida
então o que é esse azul são seus amigos
preferidos
a foto que você compartilha é a sua
banda favorita seu time de futebol o
time que você torce
tudo feito pra te agradar e porque eu
sempre trago essa informação a gente
vive hoje em formato de bolha né
acho que todo mundo aqui sabe é o que
está acontecendo no país com brigas de
grupos a conta do grupo b muito passa
por esse fenômeno que os algoritmos
estão selecionando aquilo que mais me
agrada e os memes o que eles fazem nos
agradam o tempo inteiro né
dificilmente você vê um meme ea não
quero geralmente você vê dá risada
compartilha e essa dinâmica é
fundamental para a gente entender como é
que funciona a internet nesse lugar onde
os memes é circulam outro fenômeno para
a gente entender as redes sociais e os
memes é esse aqui que eu chamo de
paradoxo da escolha na verdade não sou
eu é um pesquisador chamado belo chute
também o norte americano e vão pensar
juntos aqui sabe quando você entra no
netflix ou no youtube e você fica lá
entra com o controle remoto procurando
uma sessão dramas comédias séries de tv
você fica
inteiro daqui a pouco você prestar
atenção já passou 15 minutos e você não
escolheu nada né
acho que todo mundo aqui já teve essa
sensação não é se começa a cutucar assim
a esposa começa amanhã e aí que a gente
vai assistir a ninguém a dizer na
televisão o que é esse paradoxo da
escolha é exatamente essa sensação que a
gente tem tantas opções têm tanta
informação que você acaba escolhendo
nada
e como é que isso funciona e não precisa
nem ser na internet isso é o que está
acontecendo no nosso mundo
você vai comprar um carro você fica dois
três quatro meses pensando assim essa
marca ou aquela será que esse carro com
essa característica
o bê e você fica pensando pensando
pensando daqui a pouco as 156 mesmo
sendo conseguiu tomar uma decisão pra
isso a gente tem um nome paradoxo da
escolha e o que é o mais grave do
paradoxo da escolha é que quando você
costuma fazer uma decisão você acaba se
frustrando
não pensa só você tá lá no netflix ficou
15 minutos assistindo um vídeo bom vai
ser vou assistir a esse filme passa
cinco minutos você começa a nossa mas
podia ter escolhido outro né porque eu
sempre falo sobre esse fenômeno isso tem
tudo a ver com a nossa experiência das
redes sociais
sabe essa sensação que tal um monte de
coisa acontecendo e você quer acompanhar
tudo mas sei lá parece estar perdendo
alguma coisa que é e quer ficar
conectado no estado ela quer ficar
conectado no facebook tudo ao mesmo
tempo você fica acelerado sem conseguir
de fato prestar atenção em alguma coisa
está aí a razão do sucesso dos memes né
são curtos auto explicativos você não
precisa de muita atenção ele passa
rapidinho e você não precisa ficar
escolhendo muito diferente por exemplo
de um texto tão não é que a gente
conhece no facebook
tá bom agora uma questão muito
importante que eu queria trazer para
vocês é que o meme é na minha concepção
é uma linguagem que isso significa
o nome é a primeira vez que essa ideia
surgiu foi com o pesquisador chamado
richard dawkins um livro chamado gene
egoísta
a idéia dele assim me virar lisa na
sociedade como uma forma com uma pequena
unidade da cultura
mas na minha opinião o que é o mesmo é
uma linguagem que atende uma demanda do
mundo que a gente vive esse mundo
acelerado corrido que estou dizendo para
vocês as redes sociais né então começou
a falar propriamente dessa linguagem dos
memes eu já vi que você estava um pouco
preocupados depois disse que não vai
falar de m
estão aqui os memes tá como é que
funciona então a linguagem é que a gente
chama de micro narrativa o que é uma
micro narrativa bom primeiro uma
narrativa é aquilo que tem começo meio e
fim
certo a micro narrativa é aquela que
você encurta tudo e esse alto explica
como nesse caso aqui então todo mundo já
entendeu né que a mãe do garoto é o da
garota que compartilhou sua m fala muito
certo
isso é auto explicativo e os memes tem
muito disso além dessa dessa paródia é o
cara envelheceu tanto de escutar mais
falar
o mais importante é sua característica
de encurtar aquilo que ele tem para
dizer né
muito bom né
esses memes é eu retirei da minha
pesquisa de mestrado é que eu fiz uma
escola em são paulo e muito interessante
que esse m
um aluno compartilhou falou sempre me
professor esse aqui sou eu né
então como é que funciona essa
característica é de deboche e ironia
imagine que aqui tivesse um cidadão é
uma personagem com o papel higiênico na
mão não ia chamar a atenção então
pensando que estou dizendo nas redes
sociais
muita informação todo mundo correndo
você precisa de um elemento pra chamar
logo de de cara a atenção das pessoas
então nesse caso é bom eu faço o papel
de trouxa nível industrial gigantesco né
então essa que é a brincadeira que é
nosso companheiro que fez bom
outra questão importante sobre os memes
está relacionada aos afetos
como eu disse para vocês no começo da
apresentação os memes não são apenas
divertidos engraçados
eles estão mexendo com os nossos
próprios sentimentos né e então o que
acontece essa linguagem é que falciani
rotariano crush acho que todo mundo aqui
conhece algum tipo de expressão que
surge das redes sociais
esse tipo de mensagem de relação está
cada vez mais presente no cotidiano da
escola por exemplo né eu sei que tem
alguns alunos aqui todo mundo sabe que
alguém provoca amiga com o meme provoca
um coleguinha com uma outra zoeira
porque é isso que estou dizendo os
mesmos passarão a mobilizar os nossos
afetos por mais maluco que isso pareça
né eu sei que muitas vezes os mesmos são
tratados como a isso é coisa da internet
a isso é um assunto menor
bom mesmo é ler livro é uma tendência
que a gente tem mas no meu modo de ver
quando a gente começa a ter esse tipo de
relação aqui de mobilização de afetos
dos sentimentos a gente precisa entender
cada vez mais né
essa linguagem como é que ela entre na
nossa vida
será que a gente compartilha e me
provocar um aluno será que a gente
provoca os professores com memes porque
eu estou dizendo isso o pessoal é muitas
vezes sob é uma desculpa de ser uma
brincadeira uma piada a gente encontra
memes com bullying é memes com violência
simbólica com agressões raciais
agressões de gênero então quando a gente
fala que a gente precisa discutir mesmo
é também um pouco pensar como é que os
afetos estão circulando nas mensagens
nessa zoeira que nem sempre uma zoeira
tem como objetivo como essa imagem de
brincar
muitas vezes ela também quer enfim
provocar ou trazer algum tipo de deboche
pessoal bom
outro elemento marcante da linguagem dos
memes é aquilo que a gente chama de
zoeira e vocês sabem que no brasil de
fato a zoeira não tem limites né pra
quem é é a o brasileiro é um caso único
no mundo que precisa ser estudado né e
inclusive estava conversando com um
amigo meu que pesquisa
a games e ele me disse cara é
impressionante como os jogadores
brasileiros nem jogos internacionais é
são odiados por que o objetivo comum é
chegar até o outro lado do palco o
brasileiro fica empurrando o cara para o
lado tenta passar uma rasteira esse
comportamento do brasileiro é sobre essa
idéia de que as leis não tem limites é
muito importante para entender como é
que essa linguagem está cada vez mais né
no nosso cotidiano
ou seja hoje essa dimensão que eu falei
pra vocês de tudo engraçado tudo é
divertido a gente tem que rir porque
como é que essa zoeira entra na nossa
vida pró vamos pensar junto tá todo
mundo correndo certo tá todo mundo
ocupado com um dificuldade de organizar
a agenda pressionar nosso não consigo
fazer nada o meme na verdade essa
sujeira na internet é uma espécie de
conforto é uma espécie de de carinho que
você recebe essa dureza que a gente vive
no dia a dia então porque a zoeira né
faz tanto sucesso né não
nas redes sociais é justamente por
atender essa essa nessa nossa
necessidade de ser acolhido de dar um
riso é de fazer um sorriso
bom isso é basicamente a minha sensação
agora olhando pra vocês né
eu não sei se vocês estão entendendo se
faz sentido eu espero que sim mas eu
acho que esse é um outro elemento muito
importante dos membros essa essa auto
referência né
eu tenho uma aluna que ela sempre diz o
professor muitas vezes eu não sei o que
dizer
mas sempre tem um meme pronto para dizer
aquilo que eu queria né então os mesmos
tomaram essa dimensão e eu deixei essa
logo pro final justamente para fazer
essa provocação comigo mesmo nessa época
eu nem sei se você está entendendo que
eu tô falando espero que sim
bom já caminhando para o final da nossa
conversa porque tudo isso que eu disse
até agora é importante para a escola eu
sou educomunicador que o educomunicador
é aquele que trabalha com comunicação e
educação educação midiática e por que é
importante a gente trabalhar com os
meninos na sala de aula na escola
mesmo que a gente proíba os memes que
não seja possível utilizar os memes é a
escola acha que não é interessante tudo
bem eu acho que cada escola tenha sua
perspectiva
mas por que é importante levar os memes
para dentro da sala de aula porque os
meninos falam sobre o tipo de relação
que os estudantes estão construindo isso
é mais importante mesmo que proibido na
sala de aula o meme está carregando as
mensagens os sentidos
os afectos aquilo que as pessoas estão
pensando sobre um determinado tema e
sempre que a escola está próxima do
universo cultural do estudante mais
chances de construir pontes educativas
da educação ce mais digamos assim é
prazerosa mais dinâmica então não é que
o meme engraçado divertidinho a gente
precisa cortar não é isso a gente
precisa entender que ela faz parte da
vida desses estudantes e não uma última
provocação que eu queria deixar para
vocês
an - resolvem todos os nossos problemas
pensem só tudo que eu disse sobre é essa
questão dos divertimentos fáceis de de
tudo vira brincadeira e piada
será que pra entender o que aconteceu no
nosso mundo dá pra ser com o meme
ou será que a gente precisa estudar um
pouquinho mais só que a gente precisa
gastar um pouquinho mais de tempo lendo
entendendo que está acontecendo no país
né
e eu digo isso porque os memes muitas
vezes são colocados na escola onde o
universo de mil do meu trabalho como o
coro dos contentes que o coro dos
contentes a festa alegria vamos la même
mas será que é essa a educação que a
gente quer que é tudo festa tudo alegria
ou a gente precisa pensar um pouquinho
mais o nosso país
só que a gente precisa pensar um pouco
mais os problemas que a gente tem e será
que os mesmos vão responder isso
essa é uma provocação para vocês e muito
obrigado
[Aplausos]